[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  I'm a youth worker I work in Youth  Center Italia I work with different  projects and activities for youngsters  and also for volunteers and my mission  is to empower and encourage them to do  their best work  [Music]  during the years that I worked here I  encountered many problems nowadays the  most important one is used in a  community and also European union and  European commission really helps with  that thing  [Music]  foreign  European commission empowered me to live  with many different programs that they  offer so that I can do my work really  creatively and innovatively  for the end I would like to offer a fun  quote for all the viewers  I think that if you want to achieve your  goals you need to be confident motivated  and believe in yourself  [Applause]  [Music]  thank you